we are listening to the questions and
comments from folks through discord
davidpakman.com
discord speaking of ohio let's go to
chris in cincinnati chris you're on the
air
hi thank you so much david um so i just
want to start a little bit with a point
in which we can agree on um because i do
kind of want to pressure you a little
bit onto uh
your thoughts on the like aoc kind of
controversy
so uh would you say that
if your goal is progressive policy and
a non-corrupt government that uh pelosi
probably wouldn't be a good speaker of
the house
um you're saying in in a vacuum i don't
think about it that way i don't think
pelosi um i'm not excited by nancy
pelosi
because i just don't find her to be
nearly
progressive enough so my preference
would be for a more progressive speaker
of the house
you know absent any other political
realities in a vacuum i'd rather someone
more progressive than nancy pelosi
right i think we can agree on that so i
think um
politics 101 right you if you
don't agree with um a specific vote
right you don't agree with voting for
nancy pelosi for progressive policy then
you of course want to leverage your vote
right you'd want to
like get something out of voting for
pelosi whether that be
um a more progressive speaker of the
house which
is very unlikely or maybe getting some
political concessions
out of speaker pelosi correct uh those
would certainly be
things that one could tr seek yes right
so
um what aoc has came out and said what
she would be trying to leverage for her
vote
um the first thing she said was a 15
minimum wage
which is like incongruent
with like any sort of leverage because
pelosi and biden already said they're
fighting for that
so it doesn't really make sense and like
at best
it's just kind of misleading um and
gaslighting
uh on a second can we can i can we talk
about that
when you say what aoc would want
in exchange for her vote for nancy would
be a 15
minimum wage the language is a little
bit confusing because
how would aoc voting for nancy pelosi
get a 15 minimum wage do you mean a vote
on a 15
minimum wage or what what specifically
that's that's a great that's a great
question so
um what aoc tweeted what she said in
response
um to how she's leveraging her vote for
nancy pelosi
it would be if i vote for nancy pelosi i
have backdoor
kind of conversations with nancy pelosi
and make an agreement with her
that i will support her for a 15 minimum
wage if i support nancy pelosi
hold on a second i think you just said
something totally
i will support her for a 15 dollar
minimum wage
if i i i think maybe you just misspoke
can you say that again aoc said
what exactly okay so you can
read the tweet that she said but she's
saying she's leveraging her vote for
speaker pelosi in order to get a 15
minimum wage that was directly her tweet
she did it in response to justin jackson
on twitter
okay i'm just saying i don't fully
understand what it means that
she she wants to getting a 15 minimum
wage is something that would have to
pass the house senate and be signed into
law by the president so i'm trying to
understand
i'm not saying you're giving me wrong
information i don't understand what it
means that
she's leveraging her vote for a 15
minimum wage because i just don't see
how nancy pelosi can make that happen
is she tech talking about a vote on a 15
minimum wage
that's a great question i think like
these kinds of um the exact question
that you're bringing up
is kind of proof that what aoc is saying
in response to leveraging your vote is
kind of incongruent with
not only the way that this would work
properly but also
like um well that may be that maybe i
guess
it depends on what aoc meant i'm just
not totally since i haven't seen the
tweet
i it's possible that it's clear what aoc
meant
in the tweet but you but i'm not hearing
it yeah you i just don't
well maybe we shouldn't stick on that
then but i think the the point is still
there um i i just find it interesting
that
uh there was there's a whole debacle on
aoc's response
to justin jackson in part of this
controversy
and that was really part of it and um
that's part of what though what
i'm trying to say what is the main point
what
it was part of the is about forcing the
vote
part of that disagreement saying aoc
wasn't left enough right
i mean i'm not going to say the
disagreement intentions for aoc right
listen
i don't know that i don't i wanna i want
to i want to have this conversation
i just am really struggling to know what
you're talking about when you say
that was part of the disagreement
what was part of which disagreement
between which parties there was a
disagreement
between people on the left like jimmy
dore who's
okay there was a disagreement between
justin jackson
and brianna joy gray and secular talk
with aoc's policy making decisions
in how she's leveraging her vote okay
i'm first
pelosi okay and this disagreement was on
twitter and
it came in aoc's response to justin
jackson
on twitter um and that's what really
sparked the controversy of force the
vote
okay on top of jimmy dore's uh
crazy outward rants about how aoc is
corrupt which i don't support right
okay okay so aoc
said in response to justin jackson
justin jackson
saying on twitter that if you don't
leverage your vote
for medicare for all which is like force
the vote
then you are showing who you truly are
um kind of saying like it's a litmus
test
um and aoc responded to justin jackson
saying we are leveraging our vote and
we're doing it for a 15
minimum wage okay who is justin who is
justin jackson
sure he's uh and he's an nfl
football player but on twitter he's a
very active leftist
um who frequently goes on like katie
halper's show
and um brianna joy grave uh bad faith
podcast
okay i don't know who so let me i'm
going to try to bring this back maybe
maybe this is just not the right venue i
don't know who katie halper is i know
brianna joy gray was was bernie's
former former person were like 10 layers
deep in telephone was there a specific
question for me on policy sure
yes okay on policy i
i would hope that you could um
just a little expand on what you think
would be the best
way to leverage your vote for speaker
pelosi
like maybe we could talk about that or
you could expand on
if we're going to vote for nancy pelosi
progressives i mean and you're going to
vote for someone that we don't clearly
agree with we
already said that what is the best way
we should leverage our vote for speaker
blowsing okay i have a segment coming up
about this
and i'm gonna lay out in detail exactly
the things that i think would be more
uh more reasonable but ju
if we're gonna stay even in this
paradigm if i were aoc and this doesn't
mean this is the right thing or the
wrong thing
i would be more interesting more
interested
in uh pushing for something that uh
whole
if i'm going to hold my vote hostage i
don't want to do it for a naughty nice
list on medicare for all
i would rather do it on standing firm on
1200 or 2
000 for people that need it just as one
example like i can come up with all
sorts of other examples but i think
there's actually a bigger
picture question here about the types of
things that members of congress can try
to get from the speaker
that are beyond symbolic votes to do a
naughty and light
nice list which includes things related
to
committee ships and it's a long list and
i'm going to have that clip very soon
all right thank you so much i really
appreciate it um i'm sorry if it was
unclear but i love your show thank you
and says the leading remark brianna joy
gray had a great article on
like what this kind of effect would have
and also david sirota on how to leverage
your vote properly but thank you so much
david
all right very good pleasure pleasure
pleasure hopefully we were able to uh
make some um sense out of that
eventually i mean i think we got
to something interesting ultimately